الجماهير المغربيه همم تابعنا المباراه
وبعد ذلك انتقلنا مع الجماهير التي حضرت
هنا الى سوق واقف للاحتفال للاحتفال بهذا
الفوز على بلجيكا هناك من المغرب هناك من
السعوديه هناك من تونس من مصر من الصعيد
والكثيرون طبعا اذا حكينا مع عبد الله من
المغرب شو رايك بهذه الي صار وهل هناك
فرصه لان يربح الكاس المنتخب المغربي
الحمد لله اليوم الماتش كان زوين يلعبون
والماتش الدراري يلعبوا ماتش زوين واعطونا
امل انا نبقى هنا على طلب همم
المجموعه انت جيت من اول المباريات ولا
بجيت بس مباريات اليوم انا جيت قبل كاس
العالم
ههه الله اكبر
مشجعين سعوديين الذين طبعا يتكلمون حتى
اللهجه المغربيه سمعت من الشاب الموجود
ويشجع شو كنت تتردد قبل شوي هتاف يغني في
المغرب او يقال في المغرب تشجيعا المنتخب
المغربي اول شيء الحمد لله والشكر يا رب
على فوز المغرب وهذا الفوز طبعا هذا الفوز
موفيز الفوز الشخصي على المغرب هذا الفوز
للجميع العربيين والجميع العربي
[تصفيق]
سوق واقف اذا اخذنا الكاميرا كمان سنشاهد
اطفال ويوجد جميع الاجيال اذا اخذنا
الكاميرا الى الخلف سوف نشاهد التجمعات
الموجوده هون برده شاب من المغرب
المقبله وندوزوا الدور المقبل واحنا وراء
اللاعبين وراء المدرب الركراكي وكاتمنى
لهم جميع الحدود
الامام غريب
نعم هذه الاجواء واذا اخذنا الكاميرا مثلا
في اطفال موجودين هون اذا اخذنا هذا الطفل
مثلا راح احمله بيكون اسهل الجانبين على
الكاميرا تفضل
شو اسمك عمرك
[موسيقى]
الف مبروك للمغرب معكم هيثم ابو جوده من
جمهوريه مصر العربيه من محافظه سوهاج
كل الفرقه العربيه
المنتخب السعودي
الف مبروك يا السعوديه طلعتوا رجاله ميه
الميه وكسرته عين ميسي وخليتوه في الملعب
كيف الصبيه الله عليكم يا السعوديه
الله عليك يا السعوديه لما غلبته
الارجنتين كسرتوا عين ميسي وخليتوه حزين
وبسببكم انتم يا السعوديين ميسي اعتزل
الكره وراح يبيعتين يحفظكم رب العالمين
ايه نعم هذه الاجواء واذا اخذنا الكاميرا
من الجهه الثانيه سوف نشاهد طبعا هناك
حسود اخرى يعني في كثير من الذين اتوا على
فكره هاي الساحه ساحت سوق سوق واقف ياتوا
دائما من يربح المشجع المشجعين فريق او
المنتخب الذي يفوز في المباريات ياتي الى
هذا المكان ليس فقط مشجعون فقط ولكن هناك
من ياتون من جنسيات اخرى اذا كما شاهدنا
يوجد من فلسطين يوجد من المغرب من ليبيا
من الجزائر مثلا همم من السعوديه من جده
وليد
يعمل فارق داخل الملعب واتمنى مشاركه
والسلام عليكم
شفنا سيده ترتدي العالم البرازيلي شفنا
اسباني بانتظار على فكره مشجعين منتخب
الاسباني والالماني الذين سياتون بعد
انتهاء المباراه
حوالي الساعه الثانيه عشر بمنتصف الليل
لمتابعه هذه الاحتفالات اليوميه التي تحصل
خلال النهار احيانا وكذلك في ساعات الليل
المتاخره
على هذه الرسائل من العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه